SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER RIGHT
NOW.
>> Sean: HAVE A GREAT SPEECH
TOMORROW IN IOWA, AND HELD DON'T
I YOU, WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WARNING SIGNS FOR THE ECONOMY
ARE FLASHING BRIGHTER THAN EVER.
LET'S PAUSE FOR A SECOND.
ALL OF THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT
YOU, YOUR FAMILIES, YOUR LOVED
ONES, YOUR FRIENDS, YOUR
NEIGHBORS.
IT'S THAT BAD.
SADLY, WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF
NOT JUST A RECESSION, NOT JUST A
DOWNTURN, BUT A FULL-FLEDGED
ECONOMIC MELTDOWN, ALL OF IT
CAUSED BY THE POLICIES OF
JOE BIDEN AND THE NEW GREEN DEAL
CLIMATE CALLED AGENDA SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS.
WE ARE GOING TO BREAK IT DOWN
AND YOU AND YOUR FAMILY NEED TO
ACT ACCORDINGLY TO PROTECT
YOURSELVES.
BIDEN IS FAILING SO MUCH, SO
FAST, SO WEAK, SO FRAIL, SO
DECREPIT, MAJOR DEMOCRATS APPEAR
CLOSER AT THAN EVER TO JUMPING
SHIP.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN, BIDEN
EARLIER TODAY IN ISRAEL AS
TUCKER JUST SHOWED YOU,
LITERALLY APPEARING TO NOT EVEN
KNOW WHERE TO SIT DOWN HERE AND
WHERE DO I SIT DOWN, WHAT DO I
DO?
LET ME SAY HELLO, LET ME SHAKE
THE HAND OF THE AIR.
HELLO, ERROR
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME WE SEE
THIS.
AND ONCE AGAIN APPEARING TOTALLY
DISORIENTED -- THANK GOODNESS,
THE ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER
HELPING HIM, DAZED AND CONFUSED.
THESE LATEST STRUGGLES COME AS
BIDEN'S AGENDA IS IMPLODING HERE
AT HOME BECAUSE, YES, IT WAS YET
ANOTHER DAY WITH ANOTHER BAD,
HORRIFIC BATCH OF BAD ECONOMIC
NEWS FOR THE BIDEN ECONOMY.
THIS IS ON TOP OF YESTERDAY'S --
YOU KNOW, FOR BIDEN THIS WAS HIS
41 PLUS YEAR RECORD HIGH
INFLATION, 9.1%.
TODAY WE LEARNED THAT WHOLESALE
INFLATION, JUST THE MEASURE OF
INFLATION BEFORE IT GETS TO YOU
AT THE RETAIL LEVEL, CONSUMERS,
IS SURGING EVEN MORE, A WHOPPING
11.3%.
THAT IS NEARLY THE HIGHEST
NUMBER EVER.
YET ANOTHER PAINFUL REMINDER OF
THE FAILURES OF THIS FAR LEFT
DISASTROUS, DESTRUCTIVE BIDEN
ECONOMY.
FRANKLY, THERE ARE SIGNS OF EVEN
MORE PAIN IN THE DAYS AND MONTHS
AHEAD, AND FRANKLY YEARS AHEAD.
SO LET'S MAKE THIS PERFECTLY
CLEAR SO YOU AND YOUR FAMILIES
UNDERSTAND.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING YOU ARE
BUYING IS COSTING YOU A FORTUNE
MORE BECAUSE OF THE RECKLESS
NUMBER RADICAL POLICIES THAT
JOE BIDEN, THE CLIMATE ALARMIST
CALLED INDOCTRINATED BRAINWASHED
INTO GOING TO LIKE MANNA FROM
HEAVEN.
REMEMBER, INFLATION WAS 1.4% TO
BE PRECISE WHEN DONALD TRUMP
LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE.
JOE BIDEN LIED BACK IN DECEMBER.
HE SAID OH, INFLATION IS ONLY
TRANSITORY, IT'S ONLY TEMPORARY.
I THINK THE WORST HAS PASSED US.
LOOK AT THE GRAPHS.
THEY SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
PUT TOGETHER BY
"THE NEW YORK POST" -- LOOK AT
THIS.
AND IT LAYS OUT JUST HOW MAJOR
AND MASSIVE BIDEN'S INFLATION
FAILURES REALLY ARE.
YOU GO TO THE GROCERY STORE,
THAT'S COSTING YOU MORE.
YOU GO TO PUMP UP YOUR CAR WITH
GAS, THAT'S COSTING YOU MORE
THAN DOUBLE WHAT YOU ARE PAYING
UNDER TRUMP.
YOU WANT TO TAKE YOUR FAMILY OUT
TO DINNER, GOOD LUCK.
THAT'S COSTING YOU MORE.
YOU WANT TO BUY A NEW CAR,
THAT'S GOING TO COST YOU A
FORTUNE MORE, PROBABLY ABOVE
MSRP BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
PARTS AVAILABLE.
WANT A USED CAR?
THAT'S UP DRAMATICALLY.
WANT TO RENOVATE YOUR HOUSE?
THAT'S COSTING YOU MORE, BUT
WHEN THE HOUSING MARKET CRASHES,
AND IT WILL CRASH, YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO FINALLY FIND THAT
CONTRACT YOU'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR.
IF YOU WANT TO BUY A HOUSE, YEP,
INTEREST RATES ARE WAY UP.
IT'S GOING TO COST YOU PERHAPS
THOUSANDS MORE EVERY MONTH.
AND YOU HAVE INTEREST RATES
SPIKING, THE FED IS NOW MOVING
CLOSER TO A HISTORIC 100 BASIS
POINT INCREASE LATER THIS MONTH
ON TOP OF THE .75 BASIS POINT
INCREASE WE HAD LAST MONTH.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THIS SINCE
JIMMY CARTER, BUT ACCORDING TO
BIDEN, THE DEMOCRATS, WE ARE ALL
SUPPOSED TO JUST SUCK IT UP, GO
ALONG WITH THEIR ANTI-ENERGY,
GREEN NEW DEAL, ECONOMY-KILLING
AGENDA IS THE HARDWORKING MEN
WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY AND THEIR
FAMILIES SUFFER MORE AND MORE
AND MORE.
WE ARE ALL SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
THEIR ENDLESS LIES AND WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO PRETEND THAT THIS
WAS ALL CAUSED BY PUTIN AND THE
PANDEMIC.
THE PANDEMIC WAS HAPPENING UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THESE PROBLEMS.
WE'VE GOT CHEAP OIL BECAUSE IT
WAS DOMESTIC OIL.
WE WERE ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND A
NET EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
JOE GAVE ALL OF THAT UP, SO JOE
BLAMES BIG OIL, BLAMES RICH
PEOPLE.
NOW BLAMES THIS WEEK THE
REPUBLICANS, BLAMES
DONALD TRUMP, BLAMES FOX NEWS.
LISTEN TO ONE WHITE HOUSE
SO-CALLED ECONOMIC ADVISOR WITH
NEXT TO NO EXPERIENCE,
COMPLETELY STUMBLE AFTER
ACTUALLY BEING ASKED A TOUGH
QUESTION.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT BY FAKE NEWS
CNN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE RATE OF INFLATION IN THE
U.S. IS HIGHER THAN CANADA,
FRANCE, ITALY, JAPAN, INDIA,
MEXICO, CHINA.
WHY?
>> WELL, HERE'S A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
FIRST OFF, LET'S BE CLEAR, THE
BULK OF THE INCREASES IN PRICES
LAST MONTH WERE DUE TO ENERGY
AND FOOD, AND MOST OF THAT WAS
INDEED DUE TO ENERGY.
AND SO THIS IS REALLY THE RESULT
OF, YOU KNOW, THE UNITED STATES
AND COUNTRIES EVERYWHERE COMING
OUT OF HISTORIC PANDEMIC WHERE
WE HAVE SEEN THESE ONGOING
CHALLENGES WITH SUPPLY CHAINS,
THESE FRAGILE SUPPLY CHAINS
BUSINESS IS CREATOR OF THE WORLD
THAT HAVE MADE IT DIFFICULT TO
GET PRODUCTS TO SHELVES IN THE
TIME OF THIS RECOVERY FROM A
PANDEMIC.
YOU ADD ON TOP OF THAT THIS
UNPROVOKED WAR THAT PUTIN HAS
BEEN WAGING IN UKRAINE AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE SEEN PRICES
RISE.
>> Sean: SHE'S RIGHT ABOUT THE
ENERGY PART EXCEPT SHE'S NOT
TELLING YOU THE MAIN PART.
THE MAIN PART BEING OF COURSE
THAT JOE BIDEN, WELL, HE
ELIMINATED ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
SOMEHOW HE THINK IT'S BETTER TO
IMPORT OIL FROM COUNTRIES THAT
HATE US LIKE RUSSIA, IRAN,
SAUDI ARABIA, OPEC, VENEZUELA.
MANY IN THE MOB AND THE MEDIA,
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE STILL IN A
NEVER ENDING FIGHT WITH TRUTH
AND REALITY, STILL ON A NEVER
ENDING CRUSADE TO DEFEND BIDEN
AT ALL COSTS.
LISTEN TO THE LADIES AT THAT
HARD-HITTING "ABC NEWS" SHOW
"THE VIEW" LETTING US KNOW IF
THERE'S NOTHING JOE CAN DO.
YES, THERE IS.
DRILL AND FRACK, BUT TAKE A
LOOK.
>> INFLATION RATES JUST HIT A 40
YEAR HIGH AND THERE ARE CALLS
COMING FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE IN THE MEDIA FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO FIX IT.
SO HERE'S MY QUESTION.
WHAT DO YOU WANT HIM TO DO THAT
HE'S NOT DOING?
I MEAN, I DON'T -- I DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW, THIS -- [LAUGHS]
I DON'T KNOW VERY MANY FOLKS WHO
COULD DOUBLE THIS MANY BALLS IN
THE AIR AT THE SAME TIME.
>> Sean: ESPECIALLY NOT THIS
GUY, PROBABLY DOESN'T KNOW IF
TODAY IS THURSDAY.
HOW ABOUT THIS, HE CAN RETURN TO
THE ECONOMIC AND ENERGY POLICIES
OF DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP ACHIEVED ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN 75 YEARS.
WE WERE A NET EXPORTER OF
ENERGY, AND HIS CLINGING TO NEW
CLIMATE ALARMIST RELIGIOUS
CULTISM CAUSED US ALL NOW TO PAY
DOUBLE WHAT WE WERE PAYING.
EVERYTHING THAT'S DELIVERED TO
EVERY STORE YOU GO TO COST MORE
BECAUSE DIESEL COSTS MORE.
JOE BIDEN ARTIFICIALLY REDUCED
THE WORLD'S SUPPLY OF ENERGY.
SUPPLY AND DEMAND CRISSCROSS,
THAT DICTATES THE PRICE, AND
GUESS WHAT?
DEMAND REMAINED CONSTANT.
THE PRICE WENT DRAMATICALLY
HIGHER.
JOE BIDEN REPEATEDLY ATTACKING
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY, THEY
WANT THE LEASES BACK.
THEY WANT TO FINISH THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE.
THEY WANT EXPLORATION IN AND
MORE, ALL OF WHICH JOE IS
PROHIBITING.
JOE ROLLED BACK A MARRIAGE
AMERICAN ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AND
WE ARE ALL PAYING THE PRICE.
JOE BIDEN, AS HE SAID DURING THE
CAMPAIGN, HE WOULD ELIMINATE
FOSSIL FUELS, LOOK ME IN THE
EYE, TRUST ME, I WILL ELIMINATE
IT, I'LL GET RID OF IT.
IT'S JOE BIDEN THAT SIGNED INTO
LAW THE SO-CALLED COVID RELIEF
BILL THAT WAS NOT ACTUALLY FOR
COVID, PERHAPS THE MOST
RECKLESS, IRRESPONSIBLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IN MODERN U.S.
HISTORY THAT FIRED UP AND
ALREADY OVERHEATED ECONOMY.
DOES THE ADMINISTERING HAVE NO
UNDERSTANDING OF INFLATION AT
ALL WHATSOEVER?
WE LEARNED YESTERDAY FROM STEVE
MOORE THEY HAVE NEXT TO ZERO
EXPERIENCE IN THE BUSINESS
SECTOR AND BEYOND ALL THE BIDEN
LIES AND MISDIRECTION'S AND
BLAME, AND ALL THE B.S., THE
SIGNS OF AN ECONOMIC DISASTER US
DURING ALL OF US RIGHT IN THE
FACE.
INFLATION, 41 YEAR HIGH, ENERGY
PRICES, RECORD HIGHS, AND JUST
THIS WEEK, THE IMF CUT THEIR
2022 GROWTH FORECAST AND WARNED
THAT AVOIDING A RECESSION WILL
BE "INCREASINGLY CHALLENGING,"
MEANING NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT SOFT LANDING THEY TALK
ABOUT, THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN EITHER.
NOW ADD TO THAT THE COOLER
CONSUMER SPENDING, WEAK BANK
EARNINGS, SLUMPING STOCKS, RATE
HIKE FEARS, YOU HAVE A BRUTAL
BIDEN ECONOMIC COCKTAIL AND IT'S
ONLY JUST BEGUN.
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION IS GOING
TO STOP, SALE OF EXISTING HOMES
WILL STOP.
HOME VALUES WILL PLUMMET, NOBODY
IS GOING TO WANT TO SELL THEIR
HOME WITH A 3%, 30-YEAR
MORTGAGE, AND MOVED TO ANOTHER
HOME, AND GUESS WHAT?
THAT'S GOING TO IMPACT THE
ECONOMY.
WAIT FOR THE HOUSING MARKET
CRASH, THAT'S GOING TO FOLLOW
ALL OF THIS.
THE MAN IN THE WHITE HOUSE
CLEARLY IS NOT UP FOR THE JOB.
WE SHOULD REALLY HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION.
IF HE'S NOT UP FOR THE JOB, WE
REALLY NEED TO CONSIDER THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
PIERS MORGAN IS RIGHT.
AND JUST IN CASE YOU WEREN'T
QUITE CONVINCED, LET'S REMIND
YOU ONCE AGAIN.
>> THE POLITICAL COVERAGE --
LOOK...
SOME OF THE POLITICAL PLAYERS
AND SOME OF THE -- LET ME ASK A
RHETORICAL QUESTION.
NO, I WON'T.
ANYWAY.
>> Sean: SO FINALLY EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RECOGNIZES
WOW, SEAN HANNITY HAS BEEN RIGHT
ALL TIME.
WE WERE WAY AHEAD OF THE CURVE,
WE WERE TELLING HER DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
LET ME GET A LITTLE AHEAD OF THE
CURVE AGAIN.
BATMAN IS NOT MENTALLY FIT TO BE
PRESIDENT, AND THE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM COVERING ALL OF THIS UP,
THEY ARE THE WORST TYPE OF
ENABLERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
PUTTING THE COUNTRY A